There are experiments where people's
task is to pick up an object and they
can see the object in front of so you're
given the task.
That's the basic story.
The story is what you're required to do
is to transform yourself from the person
you are now into the person who has a
possession that watch.
It's just the standard laboratory
experiment,
but the watch is actually not there.
It's an image that's generated by
mirrors and when you move towards the
watch,
you find that it's not where it appears
to be.
Well,
the fact of the object not being where
it appears to be is an anomaly with
regards to your current plan and you'll
react to that emotion.
The first thing that'll happen is
obviously you're going to be surprised,
right?
You think this is pretty easy on you to
pick that up and you find out that thing
that you see as low actually there.
That's an anomaly.
You contrast at your desired future,
which was your aim when you moved your
arm with the actual outcome of your
actions,
so part of your brain called the
hippocampus.
That seems to be responsible for
comparing what's actually going on in so
far as you can interpret that with what
you want to have and if,
if a mismatch occurs that sets up the
whole sequence related to events and
those events manifest themselves in
emotion and in thought and in behave
most evidently and emotion.
If you're going to do something,
they've done it before and it doesn't
work out the way you expected it to be.
Events that constitute the anomaly,
the unexpected occurrence there are
surprising,
and the question then is what does
surprising mean?
Well,
it basically means that something
threatening as occurred in something.
Something like,
so what does the unknown me?
Well,
the thing about them unknown is that you
don't know what it means.
It's pretty.
It's a pretty straightforward statement,
but you see that immediately.
That immediately introduced as a string
sort of paradox because you lack
infinite information for obviously
people don't know what they're doing all
the time,
which means that you come into contact
with things that you don't understand a
lot and that means in a sense,
but you have to know what to do when you
don't know what to do because you don't
know what to do a lot and that just
doesn't just bring into a halt.
What is the case?
Then?
Your nervous system is hardwired to move
to a sort of default position when the
plans to be explicit plans that you
have,
that you're carrying out sale,
so as long as you could say in a sense,
as long as you know what you're doing,
which means that you have a
representation of where you are and
where you'd like to be.
You're carrying out your plans to make
the move and things are going according
to plan.
As long as you're doing that,
then the higher centers in your of your
brain,
the cortex basically it's under control.
You know what you're doing.
You feel comfortable and secure.
As soon as something unexpected happens,
the control shifts,
and this is something that basically
beyond your capacity to control whether
you can interfere with the process,
control shifts from the cortical centers
to the more fundamental areas of the
brain,
the limbic system.
When something unexpected happens,
two things occur.
You start to feel a little bit of
anxiety and it's not unexpected
occurrences.
It's really unexpected.
You'll be very,
very frightened because just minor
something minor league unexpected.
You'll just stop.
Your sensory processing will heightened,
he'll gather more information and you'll
explore and as you explore,
you generate information and the
information is supposed to bring me back
on course basically,
so you'll say what you'll do if you're
trying to reach for the wash and you
find out that it isn't great this while
you'll start making different sorts of
approach sequences until you end up
producing the outcome that you attended.
When something unexpected occurs,
two sets of circuitry or activated one
looks like it's dominated by the right
hemisphere.
Now it looks like it's dominated by the
left hemisphere.
Unexpected things make you anxious,
curious,
and you've been localized.
Those emotions in the body,
so to speak,
anxiety is the emotion that accompany is
the cessation of your body's clam
directed activities.
Okay?
That's you could say that anxiety is
what you feel when you slip into the
motor.
Pause,
pause for further analysis.
What do you expect it to happen so you
have to stop.
Curiosity is what you feel when it's
necessary for you to explore further,
to gather new information,
to update your plans,
and exploration is basically governed by
the interplay of the circuitry brain
circuitry that mediates anxiety and
curiosity.
Curiosity,
by the way,
and that's associated with positive
emotions and anxiety as you all know was
associated.
That's a negative emotion.
People would rather not experience it.
Curiosity or surprise is basically the
juxtaposition of those two sets of
emotions which work antagonistically.
The unknown produces conflict all by
itself.
You have a hard wired response to the
emergence of the unexpected.
You have to because they have to know
what to do when something unexpected
occurs.
It's instinct,
your instinctive response to the
unknown.
It's anxiety plus curiosity,
which is to say cessation of ongoing
motor activity plus a drive to move
forward and explore and your exploratory
activities.
Actually the sum total of the activation
of the two sets of circuitry that
mediate that response.
When you explore,
if you explore something unexpected
happens,
you don't have to explore,
you can note it and get the hell out of
there safe,
but you don't gather any new
information.
It's a good short term strategy.
It's not a good long term strategy,
but anyways,
the point is the surprise activities,
curiosity,
and it tells you 40 generate new
information,
you update your plan,
and soon you can get to where you want
it to go.
The point is the mismatch between what
you expect to happen and what actually
happens.
That explains it.